you want to know how Wild these times
are it's this wild Jen yuger has
formally announced he is running for
president oh wonderful and so we went
over this before uh Phil leonti tweeted
at him said I thought you were born in
Turkey apparently his parents were US
citizens wow no way so he was born in
tur that's that's what people are saying
he was born in tur his way into this his
parents were Turkish but were also
American citizens that means that he was
born of American citizen parents and
that would like WR Ted Cruz he says yes
I'm running against Joe Biden for the
Democratic nomination Joe Biden is down
24 points on the economy he has no
ability to make up that kind of ground
on the most important issue we need a
new candidate now oh CH thir party no I
just got to say is that going to run of
the DSA what what is this bro hold on no
no no no I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm like
kind of upset about this this website is
poorly done it is no for real like come
on man this makes me think he's
absolutely not serious at all about this
and it's like here's a chance to get a
big platform and and right this this
does not look like a leg legitimate we I
don't know maybe I'm just being a dick I
mean it looks like it's from like 1998
so it looks like he whipped it together
like three days ago like he just started
think thinking about but he talked about
this what several weeks ago oh yeah he
did yeah like a month or two ago sure
think it for years I'm I'm sure the most
the most important election of our
lifetimes we need a new candidate he
says Biden is 13 points lower than when
he barely beat Trump in the Electoral
College 44,000 votes Biden is 24 be
points behind Trump on the economy the
most important issue Biden is currently
trailing Trump when he has to win the
popular vote by five points to win the
electoral college wow he says time offer
mothers Paid Family Leave higher wages
$50 minimum wage affordable health
insurance public option fight corruption
and
gerrymandering uh the end gerrymandering
thing is like extremely naive I think
that's like yeah because like we've
talked about about quite a bit these
people will be like have you ever looked
at a congressional map and you notice
there's like a block here and there's
like a little Thin Line and then a block
there yeah the reason for that sometimes
or I should say the general reason for
it is you don't need a congressional
district on dead Farmland like that's
one guy who lives there you don't need a
congressional district on like a big
plot of government property either y the
congressional districts are where people
are right and so that means
congressional districts are going to be
shaped very oddly that being said fair
point it is typical among political
parties to try and figure out how to win
as many congressional seats through
Jerry mandering so that I understand but
a lot of the arguments they make for it
we don't want to end Jerry mandering in
in in we don't want to end this we want
maps to be drawn out but we probably
want a more fair method a more
appropriate method but I think the the
actual reality is there is no legitimate
way to do it any differently right
that's just it there's there's no way to
be like it should just guarantee for
Democrats or Republicans but anyway
outside of that you could pick like a
random you could do a random subsect of
people within an area and be like if you
get if you draw one then you're going to
be part of this
caucus this time if you're draw to then
you're part of this caucus so your vote
goes towards the the the related caucus
so it doesn't matter where you live your
vote doesn't go to your locality it goes
to a random because we're kind of
decentralizing we're it's not about like
it's all it's not local anymore it's you
know like polling place right like that
would be very difficult for polling
places to to pull off I think because I
just feel like that's such a precarious
uh bureaucratic system already can we
add to the uh polling Aggregates now
that officially declared for sure he's a
far superior candidate see a Jen Biden
debate because I feel like that could be
really entertaining Jen would run
circles around Joe Biden I think a lot
of people would run circles around Jo
Biden to that's really I want to see an
Ian Crossland Joe Biden debate like Joe
Biden would be confused the whole time
and just like what I'd love to I'd
listen to him till his brain starts to
work again and he starts to be what do
you mean he's going he'd be like 20
years younger that's my goal with Joe
Biden get him to snap out of and
remember who I want to see a Joe Biden
VC debate so bad because you imagine the
the racist things that Joe Biden would
call so true it would be so funny like
he's easy to humiliate but I'm concerned
that he's our commander so I want him to
be strong until he's no longer the
commander then I don't care what he does
is 80 years old dude he's not going to
snap out of it he's going to degrade
called
neurogenesis certainly possible neur
here you do you pump him full of NAD and
stem cellsb yeah and sure that of but
full of what about Jen joining the Gavin
Nome disantis debate on November 30th oh
I'm for it I'm totally for it I I want
Jen on the debate stage I think I think
Jen would do better in the debates than
Nome and DeSantis probably know is no
question I mean Jen Huger is a is a
media personality he said a bunch right
he talks for a living I think it would
be absolutely fantastic I I I'm willing
to bet he would say a lot of things he'd
actually agree with too yeah I think Jen
hug would be a better candidate than
anything the Democrats have have to
offer right now but I would I I don't
want J to win but that's why I've said
before it's like I'd rather I'd probably
rather have him than any of the other
Democrats at the very least I think he
could be pressured into a pardoning
Assange you know it's going to be bad
true I think his policies are bad but
I'm more inclined to believe we're going
to we would get less war with Jen than
with any other Democrat Nome is going to
be like you know just like BT or Hillary
Clinton there more Neo neol
establishment garbage y this is great
news that he's running I'm I'm glad that
he's running I want more
anti-establishment I want more you know
different uh Uhl political backgrounds
to be challenging the machine yeah we
could get him in here yeah chunk yogurt
24 who should uh should we bring him in
here with somebody to debate we have
invited we have invited this guy to come
on the show like 87 times 88 what's all
about magic number now he's on the
campaign Trail so he really wants to be
here we've hosted multiple presidential
candidates I'm just going to say I would
I would love to have him on the culture
War show with Phil or maybe someone else
come on to have like a calm conversation
about these issues I mean yeah maybe if
it was like youi Phil and him
specifically just culture War discussing
policy and and and stuff whereas you
know like irls like we have a bunch of
news articles that we go through this is
the big news Jen just announced he's
running that's why we're talking about
it culture war is Friday mornings and
it's usually much more just like we're
going to talk for two hours about
whatever we feel like talking about
wherever the conversation goes yeah I'm
down let's let's you know I'll send a
message so we can book him cool nice I I
I I am glad that he's running I think
he's better than all the Democrats I do
and I and I I like if I had a choice
between him or Trump I'm voting for
Trump no question but I mean to be
completely honest if I had choice
between
like like if this is tough Joe Biden or
Mitt Romney I'm out I gotta go with r i
don't know what Romney's up to but
Biden's so low right now I'm just I'm
just out Romney's retiring he said I'm I
need to leave because I'm too old which
is about that's admirable Joe Biden or
Nikki Haley Nikki Haley I can't take the
old man he's not there Nikki Haley I
know no way nuh not happening Nikki
Haley is like she's like I don't want to
go to war with Iran for RFK at that
point you know right right we have the
nice independent he's there for a but I
don't even like RFK is so my the reason
I bring this up is where is Jen on the
top 10 list of who you would consider
voting for I would say this three he's
up there for me yeah he's certainly not
on the I never would because he has an a
light anti-establishment Ben but he is
still fairly establishment but I I I can
respect that he argued with Hassan about
letting criminals out of prisons and I
think I I would look if if if I'm
looking at Nikki Haley and Joe Biden and
the only other candidate was like I'll
pardon Julian Assange I'd vote for I'd
vote for J yeah like that that that
issue matters a lot to me I think that
was an outright egregious evil committed
by the United States I think Donald
Trump wanted to bring Julian Assange
back to the US because Julian had
information that would benefit Donald
Trump and and strike at the heart of the
deep State I can respect Trump wanting
that information but ordering that ex
tradition of of Julian Assange is just
using a man's life for political
purposes so but you know I that's that
that's about all I can say I think
that's how it would break down for a lot
of people they would then look at what
are my top two issues and who is most
closely aligned on those even if
everywhere else I don't agree with them
I mean if you have two candidates you
really don't like you pick the one that
has at least a chance of giving
something you want well maybe he'll run
as an independent and then really Spike
the Democratic party my gosh be so funny
we have multiple Independents in the
race but here you'all need to understand
this I support Jen huger's efforts here
1 million per for another reason as well
he doesn't need to run as an independent
despike
Democrats by running he is pulling
donations away from other Democratic
candidates that's it yep and donations
matter contributions matter spend
matters and so if Joe Biden was running
as the incumbent unopposed which he
should have been in any normal cycle but
because the dude's brain don't work he's
got competition all those donations are
in his pocket it's one of the reasons
incumbents tend to win that all the
money flows to them they don't have to
beat off a primary for lack of better
term and uh uh right now what Jen is
doing he basically saying donate to me
and progressives will they will and then
not every single one but a lot of them
and that's money that Joe Biden could
use that he won't be having it sort of
feels like me and chank you and Matt
Gates were really good friends that used
to hang out a Taco Bell and talk
politics like that's how I see those
guys like temper flare but I don't care
it was more about the ideas I love it I
love that they're so intense and in
their own lane and they're doing their
own and they're willing to run for
president like the most compelling thing
that RFK Jr said during his uh
announcement that he's going to be
independent which is that it it should
be about serving the people and it
should not be about I'm going to he said
there there there has to be a moment
where you realize you're not going to
get your way on everything uh and it's
not that I think he is the perfect
candidate but I think this idea that we
have to give up the addiction to
fighting for the one side we've stuck
ourselves on it is worth hearing right I
mean and we are seeing it bear itself
out right now as as the news plays out I
cut you off I'm sorry no no no no
that what I was going to say no did you
were you always conservative or you
where did you develop politically oh I
was I was one of those 2016 babies that
was like always voted left and and um
and what
changed uh I was centor I started doing
a bunch of stories that year that were
very because I I wasn't really I mean I
was writing for like the New York Times
I was writing for all these liberal
places but I wasn't super political and
um that summer pulse happened I was
reporting on that that affected me a lot
Islamic terrorist attack then I profiled
Milo yannopoulos for a magazine which is
the first time I met him and then you
know he was saying all these things I
was like I've never heard anyone say
that before that's exactly what I think
but it was just sort of I mean it it a
basic thing of just looking like for the
you know suddenly looking into
everything that I thought you know I was
one of those like I of course I believe
in equality I'm a Democrat you know I
work in the Arts um but then I started
looking into everything I'm like why who
whoa they're lying about this if they're
lying about that why are they lying why
do they have to lie thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time